on average 18 Palestinians die every
week in clashes with the Israelis a
martyr is someone who dies for his or
her faith but here it means anyone
killed in the fight the Israelis
everywhere you go in the city you see
massive posters of martyrs it's like
they're celebrities and many of them
look very young the glorification of the
Fallen is so pervasive even mothers seem
to embrace it in some families angered
the occupation is so great mothers seem
to be pushing their children to die by
murder-suicide take the case of Miriam
farhat mother of 19 year old Muhammad
unable to join the fight herself mrs.
Farhad offered up her son instead
mrs. for hot insist she raised her son
from the time he was a boy to die in
early death she even went so far as to
help him enshrine his legacy by
appearing in his martyr video these
images were being throughout the Middle
East making a celebrity of both Muhammad
and mrs. for hot a mother's endorsement
of her son's murder suicide broadcast
for the world to see I wish I could
follow them now I don't want to live a
moment without them mrs. Farhad has even
taken on a new name boom Nadal or mother
of the struggle when your sons were
little boys did you think that you would
have to give them up
I brought them up to be martyrs to
become martyrs for the name of Allah
mrs. for HOD is certainly unusual but I
couldn't help wondering if other mothers
here were raising their children the
same way
there wasn't a definite time in which
they told me they wanted to become
martyrs I instilled this in them and
they followed it thanks be to Allah and
they reached their goal which was
martyrdom thanks be to Allah and the
ones who just started they are going to
continue mrs. Furr hot is not done
she says she's now pushing her other
children to become martyrs she took me
into Muhammad's old room now occupied by
another son martyr posters don't just
line the city streets they adorn the
rooms of children
are these faces of the dead keeping
watch over a young man destined to join
their ranks it was such a chilling visit
but the most disturbing image to me was
um Nadal's young grandson sitting within
inches of an ak-47 rifle
[Music]